hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
und zwar spiel wie who's your daddy mit
dabei ist heute der regenzeit sag mal
was hey ich bin dein vater kay kannst du
kannst du vielleicht das spiel ganz kurz
in einem satz mit vier wörtern erklären
spaß spannung action erotik bildschön
ewigen ich habe viel dafür bist du denn
also ich weiß auch gar nicht was ist der
sinn von dem spiel ich glaube ich bin
gerade das baby und du bist der farbton
präsidium bringen was wirklich noch den
oberkörper ist ein weg dahin warte
nämlich schneller
[Musik]
ich mache das was möchte ich zeigen
obwohl wir fernseh gucken alter wie
schön komme fernseh gucken sehen wir
einfach unsere eigene wohnung haben uns
erstmal auf ich habe die kerze war das
ist ihr okay so begann das fernsehen ich
bringe ich habe mich versteckt du musst
mich finden
slater jetzt jetzt finden wir mal ich
habe mich extra für dich verstecke ich
habe man die suche wird mitarbeitern
sorgt aber sucht mich ich bin da wo du
nicht denkt so ich bin ich las dass das
ist mein thema sucht
jeder nicht rein das ist nein kommt
zurück nein
wie kann ich denn verlieren
du musst dich umbringen deutlich gemacht
ich musste mich umbringen da soll der
fahrer sich umbringen das baby ihn daran
hindern oder was ich hab dich muss nur
weglaufen irgendwie das spiel doch
tatsächlich kein bisschen aber hier bin
ich kommen
oder willst du ein hitziges babyalter
was bin ich kann weil ich mich ist japan
ist im dreck babyalter ich würde ich
auch so gern umbringen gehört ja sogar
herzlich wirst du ja ich könnte die
ganze zeit zu worauf muss ich dann
aufpassen dass du dich nicht umbringt
ich habe möge gästen ich bin in der
küche vater war ja papa ich es den
ganzen müll aus dem mülleimer alles
gegessen
hier ist das ja ich bin ein zweites baby
rabenvater hast du schon mal gesehen
gestorben
aber einfach gestorben
ich hab den möge gestern wird einfach
gestorben jetzt liegt vor mir gerade so
eine grüne schon ab so leicht auf dem
sitz
das können erwarte ich will noch einmal
baby wollen was zum was bist du wie du
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ich glaube ich komme ich hoffe ich habe
ich gewonnen und von roberto blanco
ja ich habe hier tabletten sollte diese
essen wo bist du denn schon wieder hin
hallo ich auch dass ich nicht drauf
es geht nicht mehr kommen das duschen
gehen
[Musik]
ich bringe mich nur irgendwas weil ich
mit den duschen gegangen werden
so bin ich verbrannt in der dusche hat
in der küche verbindet ich könnte heulen
wollen an dieser stelle wenn ich das
video ich glaube es war sehr verstörend
weil
ich nicht wusste wie man gewinnt ich
weiß ob man gewinnt wenn man stirbt wird
wie wie unlogisch das ist wenn euch das
video gefallen hat seiner bewertung levy
ist irgendwo oben von links lukas ist
auf jeden fall ein rematch haben wir es
auf jeden fall niemals schaffen können
den leuten so gute anziehen und so was
heute anziehen
das beben hat es eine brille ja keine
ahnung schreibt mir das vielleicht
nochmal wollt wir sehen uns vielleicht
irgendwann